منذ بدء الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا يصل الى
الحدود الاستونيه كل اسبوع حوالي 300 الى
400 لاجئ اوكراني طلبا للحمايه المؤقته
وفقد دراسه حديثه اجراها الباحثون في
جامعه الوطنيه غالبيتها هؤلاء اللاجئين هم
من النساء اللواتي تقطعت بان السبل بعد
فرض الاحكام العرفيه في بلادهن بسبب الحرب
ومنع الرجال الذين تقل اعمارهم عن 60 عاما
من مغادره اوكرانيا
العقبه الرئيسيه امامهن هي المهارات
اللغويه بالنسبه للعاملين في المجال الطبي
نتساءل اذا كان بامكانهن التعامل مع
الناطقين باللغه الروسيه او اذا كان من
الضروري تعلم اللغه الاستونيه وفق
الباحثين نسبه النساء والفتيات اللاجئات
تخطت
74%
55% منهن لا تتجاوز اعمارهن 39 عاما
تظهر التقارير ان بعض لاجئه الحرب
الاوكرانيه تواصل العمل مع اشخاص
اوكرانيين او يعملن عن بعد مع شركات خارج
استونيا
السلطات الاسطوانيه اشارت الى ان حوالي
55% من جميع الوافدين الى اراضيها يجدون
عملا بسرعه لكن بسبب اختلاف اللغه يكتفي
70% من اللاجئين بوظيفه لا تناسب شهاداتهم
الجامعيه